hi there steve kaufman here back in
vancouver the weather's nice it's a
little cooler than palm springs
uh today i want to talk about the
importance of face-to-face
contact in language learning and the
reason for that is that i had an
exchange on twitter i made some comment
about language learning and a teacher
came on and said
there's too much emphasis on technology
the
most important thing is face-to-face
contact
in the classroom
so i disagree
i think that face-to-face contact
as a part of language learning is
relatively unimportant
i think language learning is a much more
individual
activity
obviously when you are reading you are
not making face-to-face contact with
anyone when i'm listening to my mp3
player i'm not making face-to-face
contact
uh if i'm studying at link i'm not
making face-to-face contact if i'm
watching movies i'm not making
face-to-face content
there's so many things
that you can do as an individual you
don't forget lincoln you can go down to
the library
and borrow free of charge
you know a wide range of learning
materials for whatever language you're
learning
so much of
what is needed in order to acquire a
language
relies on you the learner relies on you
doing things on your own things that you
find interesting and the face-to-face
contact becomes
a reward in a way it's kind of like the
goal obviously at some point in my
arabic learning i want to be in
situations where i am in face-to-face
contact with arabic speaking people and
i can converse and
and enjoy that whole experience but
there is so much work that i have to put
in
on my own
before that in order that this
face-to-face contact is going to be
meaningful enjoyable and so forth and
you can have face-to-face contact in the
classroom and in fact the
sort of language
content the
target language the language you're
learning you know the intensity of that
language environment could be quite low
it could be that the teacher is
explaining something it could be that
you're listening to other students who
speak the language very poorly
and i much prefer the you know
hearing the pure language hearing
stories hearing things of interest in
the language or reading
and getting
used to the language because
the language is not something that's
going to be taught or explained and then
you've got it aha now i understand how i
can speak the language to learn a
language requires so much exposure it's
a slow gradual process of allowing your
brain to get used to a different way
of expressing things different
structures different words and this
requires a lot of time
with you the learner
and the language you're learning
not in some face-to-face even these you
know conversation clubs and so forth
i've always felt you know in japan for
example that ego kaiwa have a little
group that speaks english
that's not going to do it because again
you're in these ego kaiwa
where we have five or six japanese
people and and a foreign native speaker
speaking they're using a very limited
range of vocabulary and and essentially
the job is and of course the intensity
of that language exposure is not as high
as
listening and reading and acquiring
words now as i've always said at some
point you have to start speaking and you
have to start start speaking a lot and
you have to start using the words that
you have acquired at the very least to
hear them in some meaningful context in
an exchange with someone but that comes
later on
it can start early but it becomes a
bigger and bigger part of your language
learning later on initially there's this
major investment to be made by the
individual
and it's and i think someone once said
well you know reading is very
you know as social and i like
interacting with people i like face to
face and this teacher was saying the
same thing in a bit of little twitter
exchange that we have
um
actually it's not anti-social to read
you are interacting with thoughts you
are interacting with words you are
interacting with the language and all of
this is helping you to get used to the
language so uh the idea that somehow you
have to have the space to face contact
face face-to-face contact with the
teacher
at some point it can be useful it's not
inexpensive to organize
uh it's far better to put a lot of
effort into things that are less
expensive
build up your capability so that when
you have the face-to-face exchange you
can really take advantage of it
i should add that face-to-face
uh needn't actually be face-to-face i
just did a
lesson for skype with one of through
skype with one of our link members an
english lesson and we didn't have our
video on we just spoke and it was like a
telephone conversation through skype
and i think even there i think it
sometimes can be
you know maybe you focus better on the
words sometimes when you actually don't
see the other person's face not that i'm
against seeing people's faces and at
some point yeah
we definitely want to have face-to-face
encounters with people but it's not a
key to learning the language and so
that's really what i wanted to say about
the importance of face-to-face contact
as
you know a part of your language
learning strategy it's a part of it
it needn't be a major part of it it's
certainly not a condition of learning
the language
so thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you